Netherland back to the Dutch that's the
message of far-right leader h wers a day
after he secured more than 2 million
votes in the general election it's been
seen as a political earthquake many in
this market in Amsterdam say they are
worried about will the strong
anti-immigration stands but don't want
to be
filmed I'm shocked I really didn't
expect so many people would vote for him
wers was convicted for inciting
discrimination 3 years ago after he
asked the crowd if they wanted fewer
Moroccans during a political speech in
the election campaign he took a softer
stance here at Wilder says he wants to
be prime minister of all people in the
Netherlands but after 25 years of
campaigning against Muslims migrants and
Asylum Seekers some say his new tone
doesn't sound
convincing I don't believe him of course
not he said he wants less people from
Morocco he wants no more
refugees migration expert Nadia burra
says it wasn't just a campaign Focus
focused on migration that led to his win
the war in Gaza played uh a significant
role um the anti- Palestinian sentiments
pushed by K Builders many people uh were
encouraged in um voting because they
feel anti-Semitism and caused by Muslims
is a big problem others hope he will
make life more
affordable I personally think we need a
change in the Netherlands let this prove
what he really has to
offer a new coalition government
possibly headed by H Wilders will
still make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer